zdf heute live herzlich willkommen von
einer zeitenwende hatte bundeskanzler
scholz zu beginn des ukraine krieges
gesprochen 100 milliarden euro extra
versprach er der bundeswehr darüber
wurde jetzt im bundestag heute
diskutiert und scholz hat noch einmal
begründet warum es aus seiner sicht
diese zeitenwende braucht und wie sie
aussehen soll
vier ziele
werden wir mit dem sondervermögen
erreicht erstens alle investitionen
kommen abgesichert im grundgesetz einen
klaren zweck zugute unser bündnis und
verteidigungsfähigkeit
zweitens wir schaffen langfristige
planungssicherheit und verlässlichkeit
die gerade für die anstehenden
großvorhaben notwendig ist
drittens wir behalten die tragfähigkeit
unserer finanzen im blick einschließlich
der schuldenregel des grundgesetzes und
der maastricht kriterien
und das wichtigste viertens die längst
überfälligen investitionen im
verteidigung sicherheit gehen nicht zu
lasten der dringend nötigen
transformation zu einer klimaneutralen
wirtschaft oder zulasten guter
zukunftsfähige arbeitsplätze
bezahlbare energie fairer renten und
eines leistungsfähigen
gesundheitssystems
tja da sind andere anderer meinung und
gegen diese pläne regt sich der
widerstand hunderte prominente
wissenschaftler innen politikerinnen und
politiker haben heute einen ein
entschuldigung gestern bereits einen
friedensappell veröffentlicht mit
initiatorin ist die theologin margot
käßmann sie ist auch heute hier in der
sendung und das ist der inhalt des
appells
nein zum krieg demokratie und
sozialstaat bewahren das ist der
eindringliche appell von 600 menschen
aus politik wissenschaft und kultur in
ihrem aufruf heißt es die auf jahrzehnte
geplante hochrüstung beendet das sterben
in der ukraine nicht macht unsere welt
nicht friedlicher und nicht sicherer wir
können sie uns im namen der zukunft
nicht leisten dass massiver ausrüsten in
deutschland sei keine hilfe für die
menschen in der ukraine
der krieg könne den schritt der
bundesregierung also nicht rechtfertigen
schon jetzt übersteigen die
verteidigungsausgaben aller 30
nato-staaten die russischen um fast das
zwanzigfache die anschaffung von
konventionellen waffen als abschreckung
unter atomaren militär blöcken ist
sinnlos
100 milliarden das entspreche den
ausgaben mehrerer ressorts die
initiatorinnen befürchten deshalb
massive kürzungen im sozialen
kulturellen und öffentlichen bereich
eine solche wende der deutschen
außenpolitik um 180 grad mit
entsprechend dramatischen folgen auch
für die innenpolitik für den sozialstaat
für liberalität und mitmenschlichkeit
wäre ein demokratiepolitischer skandal
bis zum abend haben gut 15.000 menschen
den appell unterzeichnet darunter der
linken politiker gregor gysi der musiker
bela b und die ehemalige ratsvorsitzende
der evangelischen kirche margot käßmann
tja und da ist sie herzlich willkommen
hier bei zdf heute live margot käßmann
und mit in der runde roderich
kiesewetter cdu politiker
bundeswehr-oberst ag wir freuen uns dass
sie heute miteinander hier diskutieren
die argumente austauschen und wie immer
in dieser sendung freuen wir uns auch
wenn sie und ihr zuhause mit macht eure
fragen ihre fragen und kommentare stellt
wie immer in die kommentare oder per
mail an die eingeblendete e-mail-adresse
zdf heute.de
zdf.de frau käßmann wie sind die
reaktionen auf diesen appell
zum einen gibt es das was ich und mein
leben lang keine häme und spott von
einigen die sagen glaubt ihr denn ihr
könnt mit solchen friedensappell einen
kriegsverbrecher wie wladimir putin
irgendwie irritieren das ist aber
erstaunlich dass mir doch sehr sehr
viele menschen in der regel sind es ja
eher die kritiker die sich äußern die
mir sagen danke und wir sind froh dass
es auch diese stimmen gibt und es muss
doch auch jetzt mal kritisch in frage
gestellt werden ob einfach so in
kürzester zeit 100 milliarden euro
bereitgestellt werden können für
hochrüstung und das auch noch im
grundgesetz festgeschrieben es gibt auch
sehr viele positive reaktionen
nun könnte man es ja auch als affront
gegen die soldatinnen und soldaten
gesehen die seit jahren für eine
ordentliche ausrüstung kämpfen und jetzt
froh sind dass ich endlich was bewegt
wie was sagen sie dazu
also ich muss sagen die haben auch
mehrere soldatinnen und soldaten
gemeldet heute gerade ein mann der 40
jahre bei der bundeswehr war und er
gesagt hat das kann nicht die lösung
sein das kann nicht das ziel sein es ist
kein affront gegen die soldatinnen und
soldaten die müssen gut ausgerüstet sein
das ist glasklar 49 milliarden stehen
schon im haushalt für 2022 für
rüstungsausgaben also wenn man da
haushalten ist es ja nun möglich sein
dass die soldatinnen und soldaten so
ausgerüstet sind dass es nicht heißt es
sie haben noch nicht mal unterwäsche die
geliefert werden kann also das halte ich
dann für ein problem der logistik aber
100 milliarden obendrauf im verhältnis
beispielsweise zu einem etat des
umweltministeriums von 2,7 milliarden ja
oder bildung 19 milliarden das halte ich
für völlig unverhältnismäßig und einen
ruck in richtung hochrüstung das haben
wir in dem appell gemeinsam kritisiert
herr roderich kiesewetter was ihre
antwort auf den appell
nun das ist eine sehr gute demokratische
tugend und bewegung sich kritisch zu
äußern
aber das ist natürlich sehr
wohlstandsverwöhnt in der ukraine
starben zehntausende menschen sind
millionen auf der flucht zur zeit zehn
millionen menschen die das land
verlassen und wir wissen dass putin
angekündigt hat wenn die ukraine fällt
dann fällt auch moldau und er hat die
existenzberechtigung der baltischen
staaten den staaten abgesprochen das
heißt wenn wir uns nicht um unsere
sicherheit kümmern dann gerät auch die
nato unter druck und wir müssen sie ja
klar sagen dass wir bereit sind unsere
sicherheit besser zu verteidigen die
bundeswehr war eben 25 jahre lang bis
2014 steinbruch für finanzielle vorhaben
in anderen ressorts und seit 2014 wo wir
auch auf diplomatie gesetzt haben hat
putin allen diplomatischen angeboten zum
trotz eben nicht eingelenkt sondern den
krieg gegen die ukraine mit bereits
14.000 toten 2014 fortgesetzt und diese
eskalation weitergeführt deswegen müssen
wir jetzt eine klare militärische
antwort haben und die schlecht
ausgestattete bundeswehr verbessern und
zugleich auch ein zeichen an die sich
bedroht fühlen dann osteuropäischen
länder setzen es geht hier nicht um
hochrüstung sondern es geht endlich mal
um das was die bundeswehr auch zum zweck
macht nämlich landes und
bündnisverteidigung
frau käßmann ich möchte ihnen gern die
gelegenheit geben direkt darauf zu
reagieren und gebt noch einen kommentar
von einem user mit in die sendung oper
knapp schreibt über youtube wenn wir
jetzt nicht in eine verteidigungs fähige
bundeswehr investieren werden wir derlei
debatten in mittlerer zukunft nicht mehr
führen können
also jetzt möchte ich mal sagen
wohlstandsverwöhnt macht uns 600
initiatorin initiatoren ein bisschen
lächerlich natürlich als hätten wir
keine ahnung von realpolitik und da bin
ich doch sagen wir haben einen krieg in
syrien der seit elf jahren existiert
herr putin ist da hoch involviert es
gibt 500 1000 tote vier fünftel der
bevölkerung haben ihre heimat verloren
wir haben seit sieben jahren einen krieg
im jemen wir liefern aus deutschland
rüstungsproduktion nach saudi arabien
das 24.000 einsätze dort mit der
luftwaffe geflogen hat
[Musik]
themen ist inzwischen jeder vierte
zivilist auf hilfe angewiesen es gibt
eine hungersnot die extremist millionen
kinder sind vom hungertod bedroht also
krieg gibt es schon auf dieser welt seit
vielen jahren natürlich ist ukraine und
sehr nahe weil es an unsere grenzen
kommt aber eine zukunftsperspektive sehe
ich in mehr rüstung nicht will man sagen
die vereinigten staaten von amerika
haben in den kriegen im irak und in
afghanistan vier billionen us dollar
verbrannt kann man sagen ohne dass
frieden und demokratie gewachsen werden
ich wünsche mir dass endlich aufgewacht
wird und gesagt wird lasst uns 100
milliarden euro investieren in aufbau
von zivilgesellschaft in zivile
friedensdienst in visionen für die
menschen in landwirtschaft in den
ländern des globalen südens in
entwicklung die soll jetzt wieder
gekürzt werden eine friedens perspektive
sehe ich nicht durch mehr rüstung und zu
mal mehr konventionelle rüstung bei
staaten die sich auch atomar bekämpfen
können ist ja auch eine frage die wir
stellen müssen ob das sinnvoll ist das
ist auch eine meinung die hier ein user
vertrieb suchen und beschreibt
entschuldigung herr kiesewetter der sagt
auch eine aufrüstung gegen eine
atomwaffe atommacht bringt gar nicht
viel und es macht außerdem überhaupt
keinen sinn gegenseitig mit
konventionellen waffen auszurüsten wenn
man zwei atomare kräfte sich
gegenüberstehen hat herr kiesewetter
bitte
ja ich halte diese argumentationsweise
schon für ziemlich überheblich aus der
ukrainischen perspektive heraus die
ukraine hat 1994 auf nuklearwaffen
verzichtet sie war die stritt stärkste
nokia macht der welt nach usa und
russland und hat allen angeboten aus dem
westen wie auch aus russland
widerstanden und hat auf nuklearer
abrüstung bestanden und hat dann 1994 im
budapester memorandum uneingeschränkte
souveränität unverletzlichkeit der
grenzen garantiert bekommen und hat die
kröte geschluckt dass die russische
schwarzmeerflotte auf der krim
stationiert war das war 94 und 2014 mit
dem angriff war dieses versprechen
uneingeschränkte territoriale integrität
weggewischt und seit 2014 bekommen wir
keine nukleare abrüstung meer hinweg
jeder mit dem iran noch nordkorea weil
diese länder sagen dann geht es uns wie
der ukraine das papier auf den solche
verträge unterschrieben werden hat keine
zukunft und ich möchte mich in die lage
der ukrainerinnen und ukrainer versetzen
den haben wir 2008 die perspektive der
nato genommen deutschland und frankreich
haben das seinerzeit verhindert und noch
im jahr 2008 ist russland in georgien
einmarschiert mehrere tausend tote um
jede beitritts möglichkeit georgiens zu
zerstören mitglied der eu oder der nato
zu werden und 2014 haben die amerikaner
gesagt achtung putin wird nicht aufhören
ihr müsst mithelfen die ukraine
aufzurüsten wieder haben deutschland und
frankreich das verhindert und somit
möchte ich hier ganz klar widerlegen
dass wenn man aufrüstung auf gute
ausrüstung verzichtet das dass frieden
schafft im gegenteil putin hat kein
interesse an frieden er nutzt diesen
krieg gnadenlos aus und er wird wenn wir
nicht sehr klar fest zusammenstehen den
krieg bis aufs nato gebiet tragen moldau
ich komme gerade von da ist ein land das
in größter sorge ist wenn odessa
angegriffen wird die baltischen staaten
fühlen sich extrem unter druck weil
putin gesagt hat frühere
sowjetrepubliken haben kein recht nato
mitglied zu sein also frau käßmann ein
bisschen mehr realismus wäre schon
gefragt und sie haben seinerzeit sicher
selbst auch ein bisschen verstehen dass
nichts ist gut in afghanistan
das klingt mir noch sehr nach ich war
lange in afghanistan und immer wieder in
afghanistan das hat damals uns nicht gut
getan ihre these und um es gut zu machen
müssen wir jetzt alles tun dass nicht
die ukraine sich als opfer fühlt dass
die ukraine nicht zum preis ihrer
souveränität quasi ein opfergang geht
mit 10 15 millionen flüchtlingen mit
jetzt schon über 10.000 toten wir müssen
helfen und zusammen stehen denn der
nächste schritt ist moldau und dann die
nato wir werden angegriffen wenn das so
weitergeht frau käßmann sie haben 2009
10 glaube ich in büchel gepredigt einem
kleinen ort in der eifel wo dem
vernehmen nach 20 us atomwaffen lagern
und haben damals gesagt sie wünschen
sich mehr fantasie für den frieden mit
der naivität die andere wange
hinzuhalten
das bläst jetzt ein bisschen in das horn
von kiesewetter die frage die ich jetzt
stelle aber ist das nicht wirklich
eine option die wie hohn klingen muss in
den augen der ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
die im moment ihr land und ihre freiheit
verteidigen
sehen sie wenn herr kiesewetter jetzt
nicht überheblich oder eben
wohlstandsverwöhnt dann sind das
abwertungen die die friedensbewegung
immer ertragen musste sowas hat schon
sage ich mal die friedensbewegung vor
dem ersten weltkrieg mitgenommen und
danach oder dann gesagt von stefan zweig
er sei erschüttert dass man die
friedensbewegung vor 2009 10 14 so
lächerlich gemacht hätte weil sie
natürlich im krieg staune immer hilflos
wirkt das ist sicher so aber ich denke
trotzdem dass es die stimmen braucht die
mahnen zum frieden und die klar sagen
noch mehr rüstung nützt nichts ich weiß
nicht worauf sie dann setzten herr
kiesewetter wenn wir noch mehr
rüstungsgüter in die ukraine bringen
dass es ein sieg über die russische
armee geben könnte das mitgefühl und die
emotionalität natürlich die da im raume
steht das mitgefühl mit den
ukrainerinnen ukraine habe ich auch ich
kenne auch genügend und es ist
entsetzlich zu sehen wie ein
kriegsverbrecher wie wladimir putin ein
land zerstört systematisch
natürlich alles sind sie darüber meine
lage ist ganze weile haben mehr in
dieses kontinents sind ja sie sind gegen
waffenlieferungen ja ich bin gegen ja
ich sag jetzt noch mal ich bin gegen
waffenlieferungen weil ich nicht sehe
dass noch mehr waffen in diesen konflikt
zu pumpen und noch mehr waffen dass das
diesen konflikt beendet allen ist doch
glasklar dieser konflikt wird nur
beendet über diplomatie und eine
verhandlungslösung und da wird es
kompromisse geben müssen die keiner gut
findet die natürlich auch schwierige
schmerzhafte kompromisse sind aber ich
sehe nicht dass frieden kommt durch eine
militärische übermacht einer seite
herr kiesewetter bitte ja damit
widersprechen sie sich ja denn die
militärische übermacht einer seite ist
ja auf russischer seite gegeben und
leider werden zehntausende russische
soldaten in einen falschen krieg
geschickt ihnen wird gesagt oder wurde
gesagt ihr werdet mit brot und salz
empfangen sie haben für zwei tage
lebensmittel die opfer sind die armen
russischen wehrpflichtigen und ist die
wahrheit es ist aus meiner sicht ganz
wichtig dass wir uns bewusst sind dass
der krieg zurückgekehrt ist dass putin
die letzten jahre seit 2008 nicht
genutzt hat um auf verhandlungen
einzugehen und er ist die stärkere armee
und wir helfen der ukraine er deswegen
nicht mit eigenen truppen was wir
woanders machen das prinzipielle titel
protect oder andere maßnahmen die es
gibt recht auf selbstverteidigung
un-charta weil wir angst vor den
russischen nuklear waffen haben diese
angst ist hoch berechtigt und das teile
ich auch von käßmann wir haben da ein
riesenproblem ich war selbst den mut
lang dabei allerdings auf der anderen
seite und habe mir in meiner jugend das
angeschaut ich war auch im bonner
hofgarten allerdings im juni bei der
demonstration für die nachrüstung also
wir beide sind glaube ich sozialisiert
durch eine sehr spannende zeit aber
durch die nachrüstung haben wir
seinerzeit verhindert oder die
bereitschaft zur nachrüstung dass es zu
einer eskalation kam im gegenteil als zu
der zeit hatten wir auch über 3%
bruttoinlandsprodukt für die
verteidigung aufgewandt also diplomatie
und härte nicht nur diplomatie das sagt
die außenministerin übrigens sehr gut
das smart power nötig ist diplomatie
hatten wir die letzten jahre wir sind
gescheitert die härte die jetzt kommt
ist eben die ukraine zu unterstützen
aber ebenso dass wir selbst nicht in den
krieg involviert werden wollen weil wir
angst vor den russischen nuklear waffen
haben das spricht ja putin auch ganz
offen an dass er bereit ist sie zu
verwenden herr kiesewetter in der
diskussion müssen uns natürlich auch
angucken wie die nato im moment da steht
und da sie muss man sagen es ist nicht
so dass da gar nicht funktionieren würde
wir fassen mal zusammen julia schröter
tut das weh die nato im vergleich zu
russland aufgestellt ist
wer hat mehr schlagkraft die nato oder
russland die antwort fällt ziemlich
eindeutig aus stichwort militärisches
personal da hat die nato insgesamt gut
5,4 millionen soldaten russland
aufgerundet 1,4 millionen im bereich der
luftwaffe verfügt die nato über knapp
21.000 fluggeräte russland über gut 4000
bei den landstreitkräften also panzern
geschützen und so weiter hat die nato
insgesamt fast 144 1000 stück russland
60.000 auch auf see ist die nato besser
ausgestattet sie hat gut 2000
militärschiffe unterschiedlicher art
russland nur etwa 600
groß auch der unterschied bei den
verteidigungsausgaben
2020 hat die nato 1100 milliarden
us-dollar in ihrem militär gesteckt
russland umgerechnet 67 1 milliarden
us-dollar
über den zustand der bundeswehr und was
tat getan werden müsste sprechen wir
gleich noch aber erstmal die frage an
sie herr kiesewetter frau käßmann hat es
angesprochen es gibt einen
verteidigungsetat es gibt schon sehr
viele ausgaben für die nato wir haben
diese kräfteverhältnisse gerade gesehen
warum muss man da noch so viel oben
drauf packen
also zunächst mal ist das ja nato
insgesamt und dazu zählen mit masse die
amerikaner den usa leisten etwa 60
prozent der gesamten militärische
leistungsfähigkeit der nato dazu kommt
dass es sich hier um 30 nationen handelt
wo auch montenegro dabei ist oder
albanien also auch staaten die relativ
klein sind oder luxemburg das bedeutet
also die nato verwendet auch sehr viel
zeit für koordinierung des weiteren ist
die nato kein angriffs bündnis die nato
hat weder in libyen syrien noch in irak
eingegriffen das waren amerikanische
oder auch französische kriege da bin ich
allerdings in den punkten und in der
bewertung bei frau käßmann entscheidend
ist dass wir als verteidigungsbündnis
nato natürlich für unsere sicherheit
vorsorge leisten müssen die bundeswehr
ist aber eines der wenigen die
bundesrepublik deutschland eines der
wenigen nato länder die den
verpflichtungen nicht nachgekommen sind
und der treppenwitz ist dass das zwei
prozent ziel mal in den 90er jahren von
deutschland den osteuropäischen staaten
aufgelastet wurde bevor sie überhaupt
über nato-mitgliedschaft nachdenken
sollten sollten diese gesellschaften die
gerade aus dem rat für gegenseitige
wirtschaftshilfe raus sind sollten sie
zwei prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukts
aufbringen da war also deutschland er
einen helm stein der der ein hemmnis der
nato-erweiterung genauso wie dann 2008
wie eben den beitritt planig wollten
also die bundesrepublik deutschland war
immer sehr zurückhaltend in der nato
erweiterung und es war auch eine
deutsche idee der nato russland rat und
den nato ukraine rat aufzubauen und zu
entwickeln um eben auch militär
diplomatie zu ermöglichen dazu kommt die
russischen haushalte das russische
personal verdient etwa 20 prozent dessen
was zum beispiel bundeswehrsoldaten
verdienen des weiteren haben sie viele
schattenhaushalte die preise werden
start festgelegt es gibt noch ersatz
armeen des innenministeriums und vieles
andere mehr also die 67 milliarden
können sie etwa vier bis fünf wochen um
etwa annähernd auf die summe zu kommen
die bundesrepublik verwendet etwa 50 49
milliarden euro davon ist knapp die
hälfte löhne und gehälter also das muss
man auch mal sehr klar sagen dann haben
wir seit dem libyen-krieg unsere
munitions bestände nicht mehr aufgefüllt
das ergibt es bedarf an nach ein
besserer ausstattung und an ausrüstung
dann sprechen wir über die bundeswehr
hier schreibt ein user namens uwe
schmidt über facebook der es gegen
nachrüstung aufrüstung ausrüstung wie
auch immer man es jetzt nennen möchte
aufrüsten für den frieden frieren früh
den film für den frieden was kommt
demnächst immer wieder schnellschüsse
milliarden werden für nichts und wieder
nichts ausgeschlossen putin wird nicht
zurückrudern die nato osterweiterung hat
sein as dazu getragen es gibt immer zwei
wahrheiten und nein das berechtigt
trotzdem keinen einmarsch in die ukraine
eine meinung eines users und ein anderer
schreibt es mit ihr über youtube als
soldat kenne ich unsere marode
bundeswehr von innen es wird mehr zeit
mehr als zeit für eine aufrüstung von
materialien in allen ecken frau käßmann
der zustand der bundeswehr wie bewerten
sie den sehen sie den
förderungs bedürftig sagen sie in meiner
welt bräuchten wir eigentlich gar keine
bundeswehr oder soll es so bleiben wie
es ist
also ich kann ihnen nur sagen ich kann
jetzt nicht der inneren zustände der
bundeswehr dafür ist der käse wird da
zuständig aber wir haben natürlich auch
soldatinnen und soldaten angeschrieben
und das möchte ich gerne noch mal sagen
dieser satz nichts ist gut in
afghanistan der zitiert wurde der ist
von mir geäußert worden nach dem besuch
eines jungen bundeswehrsoldaten bei mir
in der bischofskanzlei damals der mir
erklärt hat wie traumatisiert er aus
afghanistan zurückgekommen ist und dass
kein mensch die geschichte hören will
und eine junge frau schrieben es ist
sehr schön dass sie für den
nationaltorhüter robert enke eine
trauerfeier abgehalten hat aber mehr
hält eigentlich trauerfeier ab für
meinen mann der im zinksarg zurückkam
aus afghanistan ich habe durchaus
empathie für die soldatinnen und
soldaten
aber die frage ein sondervermögen das
hört sich so an als ob es da schon gäbe
das geld gibt es ja gar nicht das geld
wird als schulden aufgenommen und jetzt
die bundeswehr neu auszurüsten also da
würde ich mal sagen wenn ich die ganzen
kosten sehe die für beraterverträge
ausgegeben wurde für
beschaffungsmaßnahmen die hinterher als
überteuert angesehen wurden dann würde
ich doch mal fragen ob die 49 milliarden
die jetzt schon im haushalt stehen ob
die nicht genügen müssten wenn sie mit
vernunft angewandt werden dem
sicherheitsbedürfnis und dem ausrüstungs
bedürfnis der bundeswehr gerecht zu
werden das heißt wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe bundeswehr ja aber
naja ich bin pazifist ich wünsche mir
eine welt ich weiß das ist naiv ich
wünsche mir eine welt ohne armeen aber
wir haben eine bundeswehr ich bin
bürgerin dieses landes und natürlich
soll die anständig ausgerüstet sein aber
ich frage mich auf einen sondervermögen
dass jetzt innerhalb von kürzester zeit
innerhalb von vier tagen nach dem
einmarsch der russischen armee in die
ukraine beschlossen wird ohne
demokratische große debatte ohne große
debatte im bundestag die auch noch im
grundgesetz festgeschrieben wird für
weitere regierung das halte ich für
fragwürdig darüber finde ich muss breit
und offen diskutiert werden und ich
denke auch es ist eine vision darüber
fragen wie wir uns aufstellen wollen das
ist ja so nicht ganz richtig die debatte
gibt es ja es gibt es im bundestag wir
haben sie heute erlebt es wird
irgendwann im sommer mutmaßlicher krise
wird da sie wissen dass besser eine
abstimmung davor darüber geben und es
wird auch eine frage sein wie sich die
unionsfraktion verhält denn deren
stimmen werden ja auch gebraucht also es
ist nicht so dass das eine
intransparente entscheidungen ist die
einfach getroffen wird sondern es ist
eine parlamentarische entscheidung am
ende und die debatten werden wir mit
verfolgen können oder
sie wurde vom bundeskanzler verkündet am
sorgen
ohne dass vorher irgend jemand eine
ahnung davon hatte
aber damit ist die also das klar das war
der startschuss aber die entscheidung
fällt letztlich im bundestag und das
auch nur mit einer demokratischen
mehrheit
ja das ist richtig und irgendwo muss ja
jemand auch führung zeigen und er hätte
ja auch scheitern können damit es hätte
also einer eigenen fraktionen er brauche
die mehrheit hätte ja auch sagen können
nein lieber olaf scholz das gehen wir
nicht mit aber sie gehen mit aber wir
verlangen dass das breite im parlament
diskutiert wird und wir müssen auch wir
sagen ja die schlagzeilen in den
zeitungen sehr stark aufpassen dass
nicht hier die rüstungsindustrie
plötzlich mit angeboten kommt und mit
der gießkanne geld verschwendet wird die
bundesregierung verlangt eine nationale
sicherheitsstrategie eine forderung mit
der wir uns als union die letzten jahre
leider nie durchsetzen konnten und erst
im rahmen einer nationalen
sicherheitsstrategie kann ich natürlich
auch interessen formulieren kann
prioritäten festlegen und dann auch
sagen was wir wirklich brauchen ganz
kurzfristig aber und das muss man frau
käßmann der ehrlichkeit halber mit dazu
sagen gibt es einen ganz hohen bedarf
die munitions bestände der streitkräfte
aufzufüllen deswegen haben ja auch die
debatte ist kann fast nichts an die
ukraine geliefert werden das zweite ist
das thema nukleare teilhabe thema bücher
wir überalterte äußerst kosten teure
flugzeuge haben und dann der eigenschutz
unserer soldaten wir haben so viele
opfer in afghanistan gehabt die einfach
deshalb passiert sind die gestorben die
gefallen sind weil die luft nach
unterstützung im einsatz nicht gekommen
ist und dazu die drohnen die eben den
eigenschutz verbessern das ist ja auch
das parlamentarisch definierte ziel
nicht gezielte tötungen sondern eigenen
schutz der soldaten und der dritte
bereich ist einfach der transport
transporthubschraubern immer all das
diese vier bereiche nur zusammennimmt
sind schon 50 milliarden euro weg und
dann ist es ja auch nicht so dass das
geld sofort da sondern das soll über die
nächsten vier bis fünf jahre ausgegeben
werden also das ist nicht über nacht und
wir kritisieren an dem ganzen vorhaben
dass es eben nicht zwei prozent und die
100 milliarden sind sondern dass die 100
milliarden entgegen der aussage des
bundeskanzlers ja auch noch auf die zwei
prozent anrechnen also im grunde
genommen es zeichnet sich da schon ein
kompromiss ab der in einer breiten
debatte sicherlich noch genauer
erläutert werden muss aber vor juli
vielleicht auch vor september haben wir
da gar keine lösung brigitte bildstein
schreibt auf facebook diese werte hat
vollkommen recht ich bin selber genau
seiner meinung ich will es mal mit
meinen worten ausdrücken ein tüv
abgelaufen der pkw ist genauso
lebensgefährlich wie eine bundeswehr die
nicht genug ausgestattet ist unsere
soldaten geben ihr leben für unser land
und haben das recht vernünftig
ausgestattet zu sein egal was es kostet
dann schauen wir uns mal an wie gut bzw
wie schlecht die bundeswehr denn
ausgestattet ist thomas garcia fasst es
zusammen
action kampf tauglichkeit auch in
kriegszeiten die botschaft alles wir
alles hier so sieht sich die bundeswehr
in aktuellen werbe videos
die wirklichkeit sieht anders aus alles
hier gut gerüstet im gegenteil
heeresinspekteur mais sagt die
bundeswehr steht mehr oder weniger blank
da nicht viel besser der jahresbericht
die wehrbeauftragte hügel bezeichnet
materielle defizite als alarmierend die
einsatzbereitschaft von großgeräten
betrage teils nur knapp 50 prozent
beispiele das ausbildungszentrum münster
dort standen vergangenes jahr nur 13
panzer leopard 2 zur verfügung gebraucht
wurden 35 und geübt wird meist im
schützenpanzer marder ein modell aus den
70er jahren modernere stehen meist nicht
bereit probleme hat auch die luftwaffe
von mehr als 30 transportflugzeuge a400m
waren zuletzt nur zwölf einsatzfähig und
marineflieger haben keine brauchbaren
helme ihre ausrüstung alt und abgenutzt
ebenso übrigens viele unterkunftsgebäude
die truppe kaputt gespart nach dem
kalten krieg weitere ursache für all die
mängel bürokratie reparaturen
lieferungen alles dauert zu lange und
wenn die bundeswehr selbst liefern soll
an die ukraine laufen genehmigungen nur
zäh oder es wirkt seltsam geliefert
werden an kiew nun weitere strehla
flugabwehrraketen aus ddr beständen so
alt dass kisten verschimmelt waren
der slogan der bundeswehr alles wie
alles hier treffender wäre wohl vieles
alt kaum was hier aber
mehr geld gibt es ja nun
ja und zu den strehler kommen nochmal
2000 weitere panzerfäuste dazu diese
meldung kam im laufe des nachmittags
herr kiesewetter friedrich merz hat
irgendwann mal gesagt als ursula von der
leyen noch verteidigungsministerin war
sie habe mehr kinder als die bundeswehr
flugzeuge die fliegen können das mag in
gewissen kreisen ein gepflegter herren
wird es gewesen sein aber es traf
natürlich ziemlich den zustand der
bundeswehr und wenn man sich anschaut
dass ihre partei nämlich von 2005 bis
2021 sowohl das kanzleramt als auch das
verteidigungsministerium innehatte fragt
man sich heute schon was eigentlich
passiert ist dass die soldatinnen und
soldaten noch nicht mal unterwäsche
haben
ja ich finde das sehr gut dass sie das
ansprechen denn es ist auch ein
gehöriges maß an selbstkritik nötig als
ich 2009 in den bundestag kam wurde mir
wurde ich gebeten ja nicht in den
verteidigungsausschuss zu kommen weil
ich sonst die expertise derjenigen die
dort sind überstrahlen würde man riet
mir ja das nicht zu machen sollte ich
auch nicht aber es war so dass eben
unsere eigenen reihen sich selbst genug
waren sich als partei der bundeswehr
verstanden haben aber wenig dafür getan
haben weil wir auch koalitionspartner
hatten die wie die fdp die wehrpflicht
abschaffen wollten oder wie die spd
keine bewaffneten drohnen und so weiter
ich kritisiere das nicht ich stelle das
nur fest aber auch das kanzleramt wie
auch das verteidigungsministerium haben
sich nicht durchsetzen wollen im
kanzleramt gab es wenig interesse an
einer gut ausgestatteten bundeswehr und
im verteidigungsministerium
hatte man genug zu puren die
auslandseinsätze zu bewältigen insofern
ist das wirklich eine entscheidung
historischen ausmaßes die ich nur
begrüßen kann dass die jetzt getroffen
wird und ich glaube das ist auch
überfällig war weil ansonsten als
geldverschwendung wäre streitkräfte zu
finanzieren die nicht einsatzfähig sind
aber ist es auch eine lehre für die
union richtig erkanntes auch
anzusprechen und durchsetzen zu wollen
auch gegen widerstände und das haben wir
nie gemacht und diesen vorwurf müssen
wir uns gefallen lassen und ich bin
ihnen dankbar dass sie das ansprechen
frau käßmann wenn ihre antwort nicht
rüstung ist was ist dann die antwort
ich setze ganz klar auf eine
zivilgesellschaft auf investitionen in
bildung in entwicklung auf investitionen
in zivile konfliktbearbeitung wir haben
ein forum ziviler friedensdienst in dem
werden fachleute ausgebildet für
friedensmissionen in konfliktgebieten
und ich muss man sagen das wird alles
belächelt aber ich in meiner generation
habe erlebt dass es eine friedliche
revolution gab und anschließend ein
oberer der ddr gesagt hat wir haben mit
allem gerechnet nur nicht mit kerzen und
gebeten
insofern denke ich eine starke
zivilgesellschaft kann etwas verändern
und wenn wir früher angefangen hätten
habe beispielsweise mit massiven
sanktionen schon bei der aktion der krim
wäre die welt in der entwicklung eine
andere gewesen davon bin ich überzeugt
verkehrs man sie hören diese argumente
sie werden sagen das geld aus diesen
hundert milliarden muss für diesen diese
waffe ausgegeben ich habe herrn käßmann
gesagt werde ich gerade darauf
hingewiesen hat kiesewetter meine ich
natürlich tschuldigung ich wollte sie
nicht verraten hier auf dem schirm
wenn man wenn man sich anguckt wohin
dieses geld fließt dann werden sie jetzt
bestimmt waffentypen sagen bestimmte
kasernen müssen renoviert werden alles
was ebenfalls oder was auch immer aber
wenn man es größer denken dessen was
ich will nur die frage gerade noch so
wenn man das größer denkt im sinne
dessen auch wie es frau käßmann gerade
angedacht hat wenn man auch davon
ausgeht wir leben in einer anderen welt
seit diesem angriff auf die ukraine wir
brauchen eine residente gesellschaft
eine gesellschaft die feststellt wir
brauchen eine gut ausgestattete
bundeswehr wir brauchen aber auch eine
starke demokratie wir müssen wehrhaft
sein auch innerhalb unserer debatten um
wert zu schätzen was wir hier haben wir
müssen uns fragen wie viel sind wir
selber bereit zu geben um diese werte zu
verteidigen das ist ja mehr als ein
waffensystem wohin können diese 100
milliarden sinnvollerweise fließen
also zunächst einmal glaube ich brauchen
wir in deutschland eine ganz andere
debatte wir schließen ja diskussion über
sicherheitspolitik in vielen
bundesländern aus indem jugendoffiziere
nicht diese ja keine werbe offiziere
sondern sie erklären die
sicherheitspolitik nicht mehr an schulen
dürfen jugendoffizieren und
jugendoffiziere dann haben eine ganze
reihe von universitäten die keine
verteidigungsforschung machen ich möchte
das mal auf die ukraine übertragen
ziviler friedensdienst dort ist
gescheitert menschen stehen in ketten
und stehen vor panzern und sie werden
überholt das ist ja das bittere gerade
das mit aller brutalität unsere
westlichen werte dort mit panzern
überrollt werden deswegen müssen wir
wehrhaft sein deswegen ist meine
empfehlung die über die geld verwendung
das braucht man jetzt nicht weiter
debattieren ich glaube wir brauchen
vernünftige nationale
sicherheitsstrategie wir brauchen die
bereitschaft generell sich mehr für
unser land zu engagieren übrigens auch
das was man früher ersatzdienst nannte
in den blaulichtorganisationen in den
freiwilligen feuerwehren wir sind ein
einwanderungsland wir müssen die
einwanderungsgesellschaft begeistern
etwas für unser land zu tun deswegen bin
ich auch gegen pflichtdienst sondern für
einen breiten freiwilligendienst und ich
bin dafür dass wir uns wieder stärker
wie wir das seinerzeit gemacht haben
frau käßmann vor 40 jahren dass wir uns
an die tische setzen und breit
kontrovers diskutieren dass wir die
jugendoffiziere genauso einbinden wie
diejenigen die für den zivilen
friedensdienst ausschließlich sind wir
müssen wieder breiter in den kirchen wo
sind die kirchen in corona gewesen ja
wir müssen uns breiter wieder
gesellschaftlich beteiligen und
kontrovers diskutieren damit die
bevölkerung teilhaben kann an dem
austausch und wenn die 100 milliarden
dann zur verbesserung unserer
sicherheitspolitik unter unserer
sicherheit fließen ist das gut aber das
nützt gar nichts wenn wir nicht eine
haltung entwickeln wie wir unsere
sicherheit verteidigen wollen also ich
werbe ganz arg dafür dass geld nicht
alles ist es ist notwendig aber es ist
nicht hinreichend hinreichend ist dass
wir uns auch in der gesellschaft breit
darüber verständigen für was wollen wir
streitkräfte und in was für einer
gesellschaft wollen wir leben wollen wir
in einer gesellschaft leben die sagt
lieber russisch als tot wir wollen
lieber sagen lieber frei europa hat so
viele kriege überwunden jetzt müssen wir
alles tun dass die ukraine einen platz
findet in der freien völker gemeinschaft
und dass wir eine brücke bauen für ein
russland nach putin das teil der
europäischen völkergemeinschaft
doch nicht auf jahrzehnte isoliert also
da haben wir glaube ich eine ganze menge
zu investieren und da sind die 100
milliarden ist das letzte mal eher ein
klacks wir müssen glaube ich sehr viel
hirnschmalz investieren um die in
frieden neu zu organisieren in europa
frau käßmann bitte also da kann ich nur
sagen ja diese wetter das wir natürlich
alle für die freiheit sind und frieden
wollen das ist erstmal ein pauschal das
kann man wahrscheinlich jeden menschen
sagen da in diesem land lebt und
natürlich habe ich großes mitgefühl auch
mit den jungen russischen soldaten die
da verbrannt werden ohne dass überhaupt
wussten wo sie hingeschickt werden das
ist für mich gar keine frage die frage
ist was ist eine investition in die
zukunft und da muss ich noch mal sagen
wenn wir sagen dass unsere wirtschaft
auch von rüstung lebt und von
rüstungsexporten und brüstung auch
inzwischen in krisengebiete auch jetzt
ganz gezielt und bewusst in
krisengebiete exportieren da muss ich
dann bin ich absolut anderer meinung wir
sehen ja jetzt schon die aktien von
rheinmetall schießen durch die decke es
gibt große profiteure natürlich der
rüstungsausgaben und ich finde wir leben
in einem demokratischen land und da darf
ich die meinung haben dass ich nicht
überzeugt bin dass mehr rüstung frieden
schafft sondern ich bin überzeugt
abrüstung schafft frieden herr
kiesewetter auch sie sind wie eine
ukraine
herr kiesewetter auch sie sind sehr gut
sagt das ja wenn der krieg eskaliert ist
stehen pazifisten immer mit leeren
händen da die frage ist doch was hätte
man viel länger vorher tun können herr
hu putin ist genau so hofiert worden wie
ghadhafi ich sehe noch seine zelte da
vor dem elysée-palast also das kann man
immer sagen wenn die situation eskaliert
ist aber langfristig präventiv das war
auch schon beim kosovo konflikts oder
hat jahrelang hugo wahl gesagt wir
müssen etwas tun sonst explodiert dieser
konflikt das hat aber keinen
interessiert bis es ein heißer gewalt
konflikt wurde
herr kiesewetter sie sind selbst
gläubiger christ bergpredigt selig sind
die frieden stiften
wie geht das zusammen mit den
forderungen nach mehr waffen oder mehr
ausrüstung
nun frieden stiften in der ukraine
wer will das machen wir haben versucht
frieden zu stiften indem wir sanktionen
erheblich im ausmaß gegen 43 russische
organisation und 143 oder 145 oligarchen
gerichtet haben nicht gegen die
russische bevölkerung
das hat putin nicht beeindruckt welche
sanktionen hätten wir denn noch machen
sollen ohne die russische bevölkerung zu
treffen und frieden stiften heißt eben
auch vorbereitet sein ziviles parken
parabellum wenn du kriegst bereite wenn
du den frieden willst sei gewappnet und
der spruch der nato ist nicht umsonst
wachsamkeit ist der preis der freiheit
wir haben lange jahre uns nur auf
soziale sicherheit fokussiert von 2 1990
bis 2014 hier ist der deutsche
leitspruch der deutsche strategische
leitspruch wir sind von freunden und
partnern umgeben wir können uns um uns
selbst kümmern und das war spätestens
2011 vorbei als nämlich die flüchtlinge
aus syrien und aus libyen kamen und das
ist nunmal realpolitik und wir haben
damals gesagt das geld schenken und es
gilt dublin die warnzeichen dass es
eskaliert waren ja schon 2007 damit dem
cyber-angriff russlands auf island mit
dem krieg gegen georgien und wir haben
immer auf diplomatie gesetzt wir haben
immer auf weiche sanktionen gesetzt beim
tiergarten mord haben wir zwei automaten
ausgewiesen weil skripal haben die
briten zwei diplomaten ausgewiesen also
wir waren immer weit weit unter den
möglichkeiten
insofern hat putin dies als schwäche
ausgenutzt und wir sind machtlos da bin
ich bei frau käßmann wir sind machtlos
wenn wir einen aggressor haben des herrn
überhaupt keine regeln hält deswegen
hilft auch ziviler friedensdienst nur in
der theorie in der praxis hilft der
ukraine mitzuwirken dass die ukraine
diesen krieg nicht verliert dass sie
ihre eigenstaatlichkeit behält und dass
der krieg nicht zu uns überschwappt und
das geht nun mal nicht mit zivilen
friedensdienst sondern das geht leider
mit harter rüstung und mit der
bereitschaft auch unsere gesellschaft zu
verteidigen denn sonst haben wir keine
demokratie mehr dann wird nämlich das
was putin schwächt nämlich demokratie
und freiheitsbewegungen das stört ihn
und nicht die nato dann werden diese
auch bei uns eingeschränkt truppen und
gruppen haben wir genug in deutschland
die etwas gegen unsere demokratie haben
ich denke nur an die afd herr
kiesewetter eine abschluss frage an sie
wie sehr erschüttert sie dass das
möglicherweise die geschichte eines
friedlichen europas schon so schnell
wieder aus erzählt ist
ich bin tief erschrocken und bewegt weil
meine mutter ist aus ungarn vertrieben
mein vater aus schlesien geflohen ich
habe eine kleine enkelin die ist
zweieinhalb und ich habe gedacht sie
wird weiter in frieden großwerden ich
hätte nie gedacht dass ich einmal krieg
erleben werde gleichwohl ich gerade als
soldat auf den einsatzgebieten war und
auch in afghanistan hätte nie gedacht
dass der krieg nach europa zurückkehrt
weil schröder einmal gesagt hat putin
ein lupenreiner demokrat wir uns in
diesem menschen dermaßen getäuscht haben
rede 2001 ich war begeistert von putins
rede 2001 aber bereits im jahr 2000
begann die politischen morde in russland
wir haben immer nur die schönen seiten
gesehen und nicht auf die schattenseite
dieses leuchtturms und das bewegt mich
sehr dass wir im nachhinein schlauer
sind die signale nicht erkannt haben und
das macht mich sehr betroffen und sagt
mir aber auch wir müssen handlungsfähig
bleiben und mithelfen dass unsere
gesellschaft nicht schlechter wird oder
verroht
frau käßmann wenige generationen haben
in europa kennen gelernt dass sich
konflikte friedlich lösen lassen sie
haben den mauerfall erlebt und sind in
einer zeit relativer sicherheit und
sorglosigkeit groß geworden wie groß ist
ihre sorge dass diese zeit zu ende ist
ich muss sagen meine sorge ist auch groß
da bin ich ganz bei hand kiesewetter
auch meine eltern haben krieg und
vertreibung erlebt haben die ganze
aufarbeitung der schuld geschichte
deutschlands
mittragen müssen und erkennen müssen wie
verführt sie waren durch das nazi-regime
ich habe sieben enkelkinder inzwischen
ich mache mir sorgen um ihre zukunft
natürlich
trotzdem ich bin christin wissen sie
wenn eine ehemalige bischöfin berufen
würde mehr waffen bewachte die leute
holt mehr rüstung an was wäre denn das
für ein glaubwürdiges zeugnis ich bin
überzeugt
dass meine aufgabe ist zum frieden zu
rufen immer wieder auch wenn du das
gefühl hast du rennst gegen windmühlen
an ich denke heute oft an besucher die
ich in russland gemacht habe
beispielsweise war ich auch präsidentin
der beratungsorganisation für die
kriegsdienstverweigerer kdv und wir
haben drei junge männer getroffen die
darum gerungen haben das des zivilen
friedensdienst in russland gibt wir
halten sie besser und mehr unterstützen
müssen die gesamte zivilgesellschaft die
soldaten mütter und andere in russland
da hätten wir mehr leisten können um
diese zivilgesellschaft heute hörbar zu
machen heute ist russland ein staat der
angst wo menschen totale angst haben
sich überhaupt noch zu äußern und da
denke ich
müssen wir auch die zivilen
organisationen sich vorwürfe machen wir
hätten das meer stärken müssen aber
selig sind die frieden stiften und
steckt das schwert an seinen ort das
sind für mich schon die maßgaben
margot käßmann vielen dank für ihren
beitrag heute abend roderich kiesewetter
auch ihnen vielen dank fürs mit
diskutieren für ihre meinungen und liebe
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer vielen dank
für die sehr angeregte und profunde
diskussion hier auf youtube facebook und
in der app dankeschön fürs mitmachen und
gerne bis zum nächsten mal tschüss einen
schönen abend